hi everybody uh my name is james payne
i'm with the system dynamics group here
at mit i'll give you a little bit more
background on myself in a few minutes
but just to be sure everyone's where
they're supposed to be this is system
dynamics systems thinking and modeling
for a complex world this is a three hour
iap overview session um
making sure no one stands up and walks
out at this point okay good yes doing
pretty good a little overview of what
we're doing today uh so right now we're
in the middle of the welcome which is
nice uh we're gonna do a quick overview
of what is systems thinking and i'm
going to try to emphasize this
throughout the day that there there is
there is a subtle difference between
system dynamics the the method set and
system thinking the sort of concept and
field and they overlap and they flow in
and out of each other but they they are
they are subtly different
uh additionally um because this is only
a three hour overview um we won't have
the time to dive into a lot of the
specific tools and methods and
nitty-gritty uh happy to discuss with
that in more detail or maybe even i'm
thinking about planning a future session
with that so one of the things we
thought about what's the way that we can
get people sort of engrossed in this
material as quickly and efficiently as
possible and our thought there is we're
going to do something that we like to do
quite a bit which is a management flight
simulator so it's going to take up a
good chunk of the middle of the
afternoon
i hope everyone has been receiving my
emails i'm sorry for all of them uh the
but we need essentially one laptop per
about three to five people in the entire
uh group so i think we're good with that
so that will give us an opportunity to
get kind of
hands-on with the system dynamics fueled
simulator and then afterwards we're
gonna sit down and talk about how the
lessons from that simulation tied into
some of our earlier concepts and finally
end with an overview of some additional
resources for those of you who are
interested not only in system dynamics
but specifically system dynamics here at
mit
so who am i i'll say this i was not
realizing that the screen was so big
because that's my face is very large up
there um
yeah my name is james payne uh i'm a
second year phd student in the system
dynamics group uh my path here to mit
was was torturous
to say the least i worked for
approximately 10 years in various
industry settings as a chemical engineer
at g hitachi nuclear energy as an
industrial engineer and
lean six sigma specialist at a company
called inmar which does reverse
logistics
and then finally as a product manager at
haynes brian's on the maiden forum and
playtex 18 hour brands so all over the
place
one of the reasons actually why i found
the system dynamics group specifically
was when i decided to kind of go back
into academia as a career the system
dynamics group was one of the few places
when during my interviews with different
folks when i said i've worked on
everything from nuclear reactors to bras
their response was okay that makes sense
and then my response to that was well
that doesn't really make sense to me i'm
curious about why that makes sense to
you and then we kind of dove into it
from there and we'll get more into that
sole idea of systems level thinking um
my specific research interests are
focused primarily on this concept of
behavioral operations management so
some of you in here might be familiar
with operations management as a concept
behavioral om specifically
looks at the decision-making processes
that come about as a result of human
beings existing within a supply chain
and either trying to work around or with
that uh my my constant line and refrain
for all this is within behavioral om the
presence of people is not a bug it's a
feature and what can you do to kind of
plan not only around but with that um so
a little bit more about the system
dynamics group specifically at mit here
here are here are faculty members we
have uh john sturman nelson repenting
hashir ramadan and david keith uh john
sturman is um
a big presence in the system dynamics
field uh at this point he's the author
of and i'll talk about this later on
this lovely textbook right here
which is big old sucker business
dynamics
this has become the de facto textbook of
the field at this point there's a number
of different resources out there i'll
talk about again this at the very end of
the class but given
limited time and limited resources my
suggestion would be grab one of the
copies out of the dewey library over
here and read the first two chapters
that
greatly overlaps we're going to talk
about today and in my opinion covers a
lot of the fundamental concepts of
system dynamics and systems thinking so
very brief history of system dynamics
system dynamics is at its core an mit uh
sort of founded field came about out of
the mind of this man right here jay
forrester
and its origins and control theory so
this is this is i want to say i want to
preface this by saying this is my view
of system dynamics and this is coming
from the standpoint of someone whose
background is all sort of engineering
and operations management i view system
dynamics as control theory applied to
social systems
um again you might have some some slight
disagreement from different people in
the group but that's at least my sort of
one sentence summary of all that system
dynamics is so um the real seminal work
of all this was in 1958 when he
published industrial dynamics which was
sort of the first formalization of these
concepts that we're going to be talking
about today jay forster himself if
anyone here has a background electrical
engineering might recognize his name
he's the original inventor of ram so his
uh background is primarily around
computers he was involved in the world
warden one which sorry whirlwind one
which was mit's first multi-purpose
digital computer so he did a lot of work
in digital computing a lot of work in
the electronic space actually if you go
up to the fourth floor room uh
450 it's a jay forester conference room
in there there are pictures of him uh on
his ranch that that he grew up on
there's pictures there's chunks of
memorabilia from his history of system
dynamics there's also an original piece
of sort of hand woven ram shoved up
there so if you have any interest in
sort of early computing history that's
kind of a fun bookshelf to to wander
through and and touch and feel
so really how this started was he came
to sloan and uh had this idea of like
what can i do to take my background in
sort of engineering and apply it to
business systems and this kind of was
born out of his view that often when
faced with a problem in this space you
could get so far with treating it as a
purely engineering problem and
ultimately you end up running into
social issues you run into bureaucratic
issues you run into structural issues
inside the organization that are
ultimately trying to implement this
solution that have to become part of the
solution and of itself
so he asked himself how can i broaden
and apply some of this theory that i've
already learned and developed over the
course of my life to this sort of wider
concept of social systems is a real sort
of uh test of that came in two forms one
was an early project with general
electric at an appliance plant and they
noticed that they had this three-year
cycle specifically with with regards to
their uh employment history of sort of
boom and bust of a host of people coming
on board onboarding onboarding
onboarding and then mass quits every
three years and the question was where
is this coming from what's happening so
he sat down and hand coded one of the
first what we consider to be sort of
like system dynamics models within this
field uh and presented it and that led
to his work in industrial dynamics major
breakthrough for decision makers where
this got a lot of attention and kind of
spread beyond just sort of our group
here at mit was when he was invited to
the club of rome
and started applying some of this work
to larger social systems in his world
two simulation uh this led um
to uh a book later on i'm sure you guys
have heard uh called the limits of
growth limits to growth which is in of
itself a fundamental book in within
system dynamics but also a little bit
controversial in the form of that it was
semi-misconstrued as making concrete
predictions for the future instead it
was trying to make some comments about
the overarching social structures we
live in and the limits of resource uh
renewal and regeneration uh so that's
kind of our my quick background of where
we are and how we are what's interesting
is is that what that's led to is a group
here
that has a wide wide background so this
these are the current phd students in
our group with me down there in the
middle again uh we have two other
members in the room we have we have jose
back there in the corner
we have ty sitting over here it's going
to call them out yeah so but if you look
up here the reason i have this up here
partially so you can hunt us all down
later on if you have questions and then
also for this little line below uh what
we where we all came from and how we all
got here and you'll notice that it's
kind of all over the place we have some
engineering we have some aeronautics we
have electrical we also have biology we
have geophysics we have applied
mathematics so uh folks come to system
dynamics through a variety of different
means and methods but ultimately
what at least my opinion on this is it's
from someone taking a systematic
approach and noticing that a systematic
approach by its very nature must exist
within a system and how can we apply
that more widely
so just to give you an idea of where
this can kind of lead i'm gonna give you
two examples of some research that i'm
currently working on i'll get back to
this later on this one is one that i
consider to be more traditional system
dynamics in the sense that you've
noticed this lovely little diagram which
we'll talk more about later on
stock and flow diagram compartmental
model this is applying uh concepts of
systems thinking that we'll talk about a
little bit more later on to this idea of
nonprofit organizations and
decision-making within that space and
specifically how non-profits uh within
uh
the sort of performance landscape in
which they operate are subject to unique
and differ and different pressures that
for-profits uh are not subject to and
this is this none of you should be
surprised by that sentence that's not a
crazy thing but by its very nature you
create this sort of and by the outcome
of this paper this performance landscape
that says that not only is it more
difficult to be a non-profit in certain
settings it is it is structurally
impossible for you to achieve certain
types of goals
so that's something this in the whole
whole line with this is sort of like why
is it so difficult to be a non-profit
manager under certain circumstances
that's kind of where it came from
totally different
chain of research here is this idea of
multi-uh echelon supply chains and
inventory oscillation this is built on a
classic um
um
model within this space has anyone here
ever played the beer game
bare game got a couple hands so this is
ultimately looking at the beer game of
me being frustrated and saying we've
been talking about the beer game for 60
years
like why why are we still talking about
it what's going on in this space so this
is taking uh idea of um
uh again the idea of people being people
letting their order behavior be what it
is and talk about what can we do for
sort of an algorithmic approach to
control mechanisms that exist within a
supply chain with delays so in this case
i'm not really doing a lot with what one
would consider to be sort of traditional
system dynamics tools but i'm spending a
lot of time in tensorflow i'm spending a
lot of time in python i'm spending a lot
of time
uh doing optimization within these
spaces uh and that still within is
within this larger concept of uh system
dynamics and systems thinking
so let's dive in a little bit more i've
been saying system dynamics and systems
thinking a lot and you guys are in a
three-hour overview session so i'm
assuming that most of you guys don't
necessarily have a strong background on
this actually that's a good question to
ask right now has anyone here taken any
of the system dynamics classes here at
mit already
okay good because otherwise this will be
really repetitive for you so that's
great okay
um so who here has ever seen a diagram
that looks like this does this look
familiar you have a problem you identify
the problem you gather data you evaluate
alternatives you select a solution and
you implement it anyone here ever worked
in project management anyone here ever
worked in that sort of environment yeah
so my background's um lean six sigma uh
once upon a time and this is a highly
simplified version of the idea of like
domeak though for those of you who have
a background on lead six sigma and no
domaic don't jump ahead of me because
because i'm gonna i'm gonna get to
something important here
so within this concept of of sort of
identifying a problem finding a solution
and implementing it
ultimately what we're talking about is
that we have some sort of goal we want
to fix a problem we're going to make
some sort of decision
by making that decision we're going to
change the state of our system great we
did it
congratulations
i'm assuming partially given away by the
title of this section of the slides
you can kind of tell that this is not
complete also just by the nature of how
i've arranged these variables on this
board
i'm kind of giving away where i'm going
with some of this because at the end of
the day this is not
true and of itself this is all embedded
in a larger system that matters in the
short term so when you change the state
of your system
your decisions have to change
suddenly when you've changed how you
might
implement or control a specific uh
structural process within i don't know
your supply chain the way that you go
about
managing that supply chain on daily
basis is now different
additionally because of that change
maybe now your goals are a little bit
different before you're trying to again
i'm going to talk in in the language of
of supply chain you're you're you're
shooting for that semi-arbitrary number
of 60 uh
3.4 defects per million opportunities
which i have a whole nother soapbox
about whether why that number is not the
appropriate number to choose
um
and now you've done it so now you wanna
do something else so now your goals have
changed
but now all of a sudden by you doing
this you suddenly realize that you're
affecting
not only other your one process but
other processes other things within your
system and that can lead this thing we
call side effects
but however like maybe by me changing
the state of my system suddenly a
supplier has to change how they're
acting for me suddenly maybe an order
stream has to change somebody outside of
myself and my team has to change their
decisions based upon the state of the
system
and additionally that state of the
system feeds in right there
so you can see where i'm kind of going
with this and additionally when
everything's said and done and you've
built this lovely process up with
everyone their own side effects and
building off everything else like that
here's the fun bit none of this happens
instantaneously
there are delay
after delay
after delay after delay
so you making a choice today
that affects your system and achieves
that goal within that open loop thinking
model ultimately can come right back
around and affect that original input
again this is the fundamental concept of
systems level thinking no decision you
make exists in isolation
no process that you affect exists in
isolation the only difference is the
boundaries of your system in fact i go
so far as to say there are no such thing
as side effects there are simply effects
that you have not thought about yet
so what is a system a system is any set
of interdependent parts with a common
purpose now the common purpose i'll be
honest is a bit of a
a bit of a caveat because as you can
probably tell from this if you take the
systems level concept and apply it ad
nauseum suddenly you have a system of
every atom of the universe and that
ultimately is not
feasible you do eventually have to draw
a boundary around your system so for our
purpose very generally we're going to
say that define a purpose and then your
system is all those parts that would
exist within that purpose
and i put my animations out of order
there apparently social and economic
systems are highly complex they're
dynamic tightly coupled and by that what
i mean is when one thing happens it you
can trace it to another thing occurring
somewhere else governed by feedback
ultimately the decision you make affects
something that then affects that same
decision process in the future
non-linear limited information and
there's ambiguity and typically they're
more complex than human-made physical
systems
and so ultimately when you take a lovely
little diagram like this of one thing
kind of water flowing down water flowing
down water flowing down the part that
people often forget is that feedback a
loop that goes right back up to the top
again
so
when we talk about systems thinking and
system dynamics
it's really a framework to help close
the loops i talked about before this
idea of open loop thinking it's our
method of taking that process and saying
what are the processes that i make
downstream what are the choices i make
downstream and how do they come back and
affect that first starting point at the
beginning of the day
ultimately what we try to do within
system dynamics we have we have a
general framework for figuring this sort
of process out as best we can a big part
of it is eliciting mental models
and mental models in that sense is
saying walking up to somebody and saying
i know you're acting rationally i know
the choices that you make are the ones
that you think are best for the
information set that you have right now
i want to know why i want to build a
model of your mental process
that when i run it and i look at it it
makes complete sense and then take that
model and then pop it in the context of
a larger system and see how those
decisions start coming back and
affecting the outcome and then that's
exactly right taking that mental model
and expanding it outwards and saying
okay now you've made choices how can we
bring feedback into account
simulation so this is one thing uh for
those of you who might have a small
inkling of the system dynamics group
here at mit a huge chunk of what we do
is simulation because at the end of the
day it's a heck of a lot cheaper quicker
to simulate a social process and changes
and and um tweaks or or or impacts or
effects than actually going out there
and doing it directly on social systems
turns out it takes a long time and often
makes people grumpy if you do it
directly so simulation is really really
helpful so simulation helps also
improving mental models by presenting
folks with people
also as a teaching tool showing folks
sort of self-contained
models and simulations of a process that
both shows how their mental model fits
and makes sense and is perfectly
rational but then also in a larger
context can uh affect uh and have uh
feedback
um
so this is the big one the simulation's
purpose is not to be right
this is this is i put this up here
partially for my own uh my own
edification my own my own learning i
spend way too much time building these
models both within the sort of core
system dynamics tools that we'll talk
about a little bit later and also within
my own
sort of
side environments of saying okay i want
to get this this simulation to match
some reference mode of data as closely
as possible and the question there is
though
being right is not the same as being
useful
so you want to make sure that you're
identifying the high leverage sort of
policy choices within your model the the
the portions of that multi-loop
mode of thinking we talked about earlier
that actually affect the outcome that
you care about not necessarily uh have a
simulation that directly matches the
physical
universe around us
this is these are next what i consider
to be some of the three core points of
systems thinking and systems dynamics
and this is the big one structure
generates behavior if you walk into a
system dynamics conference if you walk
into any room with enough people who do
system dynamics for more than five
minutes eventually someone's going to
say this
structure generates behavior
and i'm going to come up and spend a
little bit more time on this in a few
minutes the whole idea of structure
generates behavior is that you
the the actions that people take
are possible feasible and rational
because of the universe in which they
exist
and it's important to realize that and
and that actually goes into that mental
models matter a lot so physical
structure when we talk about structure
it's not just the physical structure of
your system it's a structure that exists
within people's heads it's the choices
that they make when they take an input
and then do an output again my
background's all
process control and process engineering
so one way you can think of this is
little tiny little tiny pid controllers
floating around in the universe taking
inputs and outputs however figuring out
what those inputs and outputs are
and how people convert that information
is is difficult and should not be
casually assumed away
and then finally the fundamental
attribution error this is something that
i added back in here because this idea
that our first instinct is to blame the
people and not the system and this goes
back to this idea of structure generates
behavior so like for example if you're
if you're on the highway and suddenly
someone cuts you off
what's your initial reaction
screw that guy what the heck honk honk
honk
now suddenly you're on the highway and i
don't know you're late to get somewhere
you gotta for me i got a call that my
kid is throwing up at preschool i gotta
get there the next 10 minutes what do i
do i cut somebody off saying sorry it's
okay and i zoom off
so in that situation in that first
situation when i'm hong kong [ __ ] that
guy that guy who just cut me off what's
wrong with them something is wrong with
that person
no there's an underlying reason there's
an underlying rationality behind what
they're doing
i will argue that there might be
rationality that person just really bad
at driving but hopefully that's not it
but
the idea that the fundamental
attribution error is that our first
instinct is to blame the people and not
the system back to structure generates
behavior it is the structure of the
system that matters
less so than the behavior and even
within our group
here at mit we have to remind ourselves
of this idea of the fundamental
attribution error and we try to break
away from it we're not perfect at it
this is written on the whiteboard up in
our room uh this is one of the first
things i saw when i walked up to that
group and um at the time i just thought
it was a nice saying and i didn't
realize this was actually addressing one
of the fundamental sort of uh decision
making fallacies that we have to
overcome assisting system dynamicist
says the basic assumption we believe
that everyone in this community is
intelligent and capable cares about
doing their best and acts with integrity
and wants to learn
so the assumption is is that every
person you meet every person you sit
down with has this operating in the
background then you have to assume that
they are rational caring human beings
who are doing what they think is best
and the moment that you accept that then
suddenly it's not the person you have to
change it's the system in which they're
operating that needs to get shifted
so stretch this some more uh just kind
of burning into this whole structure
generates behavior you have patterns of
behavior so events are events are the
most visible
underneath events you have patterns of
behavior under that you have structure
so when you look out into the universe
and you see something those are the
events you see those things happening
over and over again those become
patterns of behavior and then the system
under which it that's generating it is
the actual structure so here's an
example uh this is all about oil prices
drunk trader causes spike in oil prices
oil prices keep falling this is why opec
rumors continue to pull oil prices
prices higher uh opec
turns for high oil prices another
economic worry tumbling oil prices oil
prices after tanker attack on the gulf
of oman so in this case each one of
these ones you've noticed they're
talking about oh prices jumping up oil
prices going down although prices
jumping up oil prices going down these
are the events that you see these are
the points of data the pattern
is a little bit more interesting you
take each one of those effects you can't
just draw a line out and add infinite
you want to look at something like this
so in this case you can see the oil
prices and i would see this as a true as
a sort of a stereotypical boom and bust
pattern it goes up it goes down for
quite some time goes up and then goes
down goes up and then goes down i would
actually even boil in here and say that
it looks like the the amount of noise
around this up and down pattern is
increasing over time which in of itself
is a little bit interesting
but ultimately it's that structure in
the background that matters there's the
physical structure
there's the information availability and
then there's also the actual mental
model of the actors involved in the
process
so we talk about this this is the whole
thing whenever you talk about mental
models within this space one of the
things that's easy to say is like okay
well you tell people about this
you tell them to consider feedback you
tell them to incorporate this
information around them that that'll fix
it that'll fix it
no it is incredibly difficult to learn
and change in a dynamically complex
environment and these are just some of
the information
uh some of the reasons why um
i'm not gonna walk through all of these
i think everyone in this room probably
is on the same page with me on this one
one thing i'll point out right there is
limited information and time delays
gigantic reason people can only make the
decisions
uh given the information they have
available to them in the structure in
which they're able to operate to expect
someone to operate otherwise is to
expect them to be omniscient in some way
shape or form and ultimately that is not
feasible within a larger system
so system dynamics in my mind the system
dynamics group here at mit is really
applied systems thinking it is not a
method is not a model necessarily it is
taking these concepts of systems
thinking and applying them in ways where
we can get research outputs that
ultimately improve uh some sort of
either social system or um
actually some sort of social system for
the world
um so now so having said all that about
systems thinking i'm not going to time
to dive into some specific actual tools
that we can go ahead and use here within
this space and make sure how we're doing
here with time we're doing great
all right so
systems thinking ultimately and system
modeling is an iterative approach there
is no right answer uh at the very
beginning there is there is only the
answer that you think is good enough to
solve or address the problem you care
about it's a spiral approach just like
everything else we'll talk about open
loop thinking the process of building a
system dynamics model is an attempt to
close the loops and it's not just
compartmental models so when people talk
about system dynamics models if you hear
that phrase what they're likely talking
about is this lovely thing over here
this is from one of one of my papers
that i'm working on right now uh we'll
talk about this in more detail in a
second it's called stock and stock and
flow diagram or compartmental model
this is often confounded with system
dynamics the field uh it's partially
because this is the sort of go-to
modeling choice for many people in
system dynamics and this is also sort of
the first modeling choice back in the
50s 60s and 70s when approaching these
sort of systems
and then of course it says where all
models are wrong but some models are
useful at the end of the day
so
when you're taking a spiral approach to
systems modeling what you want to do is
you pick something within this within
this setup you think okay what's a
reference mode so by reference mode i
mean what is a mode of behavior that you
can observe and sort of pin down
this person made this decision under
when exposed to these uh inputs and had
this output great we have a reference
mode can i build a model that reflects
that reference mode awesome now that
i've done that let's go ahead and add a
new reference mode can i make this
reference mode exist within my existing
diagram nope let's go ahead and add more
structure and as you add that more
structure maybe it comes back and and it
feeds back into itself and you have to
go back and kind of re rework from the
very beginning this is where this
concept of simulation becomes really
really helpful because when you
interview somebody
as i've done with some of the work uh in
the especially nonprofit space you might
get six different stories describing
three different outcomes across two
different possible modes of behavior and
the question there is how the heck do i
incorporate this all into a sort of
dynamic model at the very beginning my
argument there is you don't pick one
pick one and model it then when you're
done pick another one and model that one
and then see okay what what how do they
overlap how do they fit into each other
how can you make this one sort of
unified model and the big thing is as
you're going through this whole process
doing your sensitivity analysis and your
testing you're going back through and
updating your own sort of assumptions
and mental models about what you think
the problem is to begin with this idea
of spiral approach
so okay now we're actually going to
jump into some actual so i said before
that system dynamics are not
compartmental models i'm not going to
teach you guys about compartmental
models because i use them a lot in
system dynamics so this is fun so uh
causal links a causal link is a
fundamental tool so causal link is
simply saying if one thing changes
another thing changes this is super
simple so let's start this one your
production you have inventory and you
have shipments if i increase my
production of a good
what should happen to my inventory
this is not a trick question
it's going to go up woo if i increase my
shipments of a good what's going to
happen to my inventory it's going to go
down you guys are woo you guys are great
so there you go so this is this is these
are causal loops for causal links
similarly let's say i have orders booked
and now you could argue that there's
some missing components in here but
we're keeping this really high ended if
i have more sales force what in general
what do you think would happen to the
number of orders i have booked
increase yep if i increase my price how
many orders do you think i'm gonna get
they're gonna go down exactly yeah
pretty straightforward one more and then
i'll leave you guys along with this one
population more people are born
it's gonna go up more people die it's
gonna go down great causal links
straightforward where it gets a little
tricky is
when you have an ambiguity if all sudden
you say to yourself well you know
salesforce i don't know about that
maybe if i hire too many people with my
sales force then suddenly they start
conflicting with each other maybe they
start going after each other maybe they
they start overlapping and maybe
customers get annoyed because they get
too many calls so maybe we'll go down
the moment you have this idea that that
causal sign could be a plus or minus
that implies that there's something in
the middle that means that that loop
does not exist and of itself there's
structure that you have missing that you
need to add
now something also too kind of the same
idea causal
thinking and some of you guys might have
seen this already causal thinking is
truly causal thinking it needs to be
causal not
purely corollary so ice cream so this is
this is generally true as ice cream
sales goes up so does the murder rate
so next time they open up a new baskin
robbins we should maybe change towns i
guess that's what that means
now as you guys can probably guess what
that really means is that there's
something missing this is not truly
causal
instead we have the average temperature
as the average temperature goes up it's
people start interacting with each other
more they start going outside more just
the amount of incidence of people kind
of interacting goes up murder rate
happens to go up additionally people
want more ice cream so there in that
case we have something in between so
something keep in mind when you when you
build a causal loop diagram is that word
causal when you're putting this together
and then if you have time i would
encourage you guys to go to like i'm
gonna try to i'm gonna i'm gonna run
these slides by um
the the faculty to make sure there's
nothing in here that i'm not supposed to
share but assuming i can i'm gonna send
this out to everybody as well so you
have access to these slides one of my
favorite websites spurious correlations
um they have all sorts of fun little
things like that uh so now bring it all
together into a loop
so in this case we have a basic loop of
employee skill versus customer
satisfaction complaints manager's time
spent resolving customer issues and
manager time spent coaching employees
let's just i'm gonna walk through this
really quickly again we only have a few
hours to talk so normally this would be
a little if you guys end up taking one
of the system dynamics classes
we step through this very carefully yeah
what do you mean by
so
so causal in and of itself you raise an
excellent point causal in of itself is
the degree to which you have confidence
on it so at the end of the day causality
is the realm of mathematicians and
physicists in my opinion um true true uh
unresolved causality so causality in the
sense that uh if if one thing occurs the
other thing if and only one thing occurs
if and only if the other thing occurs
that they truly are connected in time
and space when one happens the other one
follows
corollary is that that may still hold
true but the reason they're happening is
between because of an in-between
mechanism that is driving both
so
where this gets kind of tricky
is the lines of causality
become blurred when you start talking
about macro social systems
and ultimately they this is the same
idea that all models are wrong but some
models are useful there's a certain
point of time where you have to kind of
pump the brakes and say all right this
is this is causal enough for my purposes
and i'm going to move on but the same
thing when you set the moment you have
an um a
time where that loop polarity can shift
where suddenly something increasing
causes another thing to increase
now suddenly that same thing increasing
is causing everything to decrease those
are no longer causally related in space
and time there's something in between
there's some mechanism in between that's
causing that thing to go up in this
direction causes this other thing to go
up and or down depending upon some in
between circumstance the moment that
degree of specificity is necessary then
something that causal link needs to get
split out into into more uh detailed
structure maybe i'm diving into too much
detail is that helpful
kind of
you mentioned physics but like you know
there's a perspective of physics in
which you know you actually look at like
the physics equations there is no real
such thing as causality they're just
states of the universe that are
mathematically consistent in states of
the universe that are not so yeah it's
causality so it's like you know
causality really depends on like the
assumptions of your system like you're
assuming that things could have been
different in reality they couldn't have
yeah so i guess i guess
yeah and the operational definition of
you you're completely is your background
either physics or mathematics
there we go so yeah no no no this you
you raised an excellent point because i
had the same conversation with a couple
other folks in the physics group um and
within our what it boils down to within
our sort of social system modeling our
definition of causality is is loose at
best uh but ultimately boils down to if
one thing moves in one direction another
thing moves in the same direction
consistently every time
uh at the moment that you can't say the
phrase consistently every time then that
concept of causality breaks down just to
you yeah so when you're dealing with
social systems does it become a little
bit less if and only if and more
statistical
yeah to be to be very honest with you i
have to be careful because i think some
folks in the group might disagree with
me on on this but again my background
coming from sort of control theory and
and operations management is that uh the
the realm of causality and the realm of
correlation are are our
sort of degrees of convenience at the
end of the day
this is a gigantic asterisk in the top
corner this is the opinion of james
payne please do not
necessarily tell other faculty that that
that's me but yes it is it is a division
of convenience and ultimately what boils
down to me is that if you shove
something in one direction does another
thing constantly move the same way
every single time the moment that it
doesn't then that then that they're no
longer coupled within these systems
that's the very sort of
hand wavy simplistic way of approaching
it
all else being equal that's a good point
all else being equal
so here i'm going to go through these
loops real quick this is good so this i
think is pretty straightforward this is
the whole idea that as your employee's
skill is very general employee still
skill goes up your customer satisfaction
goes up customer satisfaction goes up
complaints go down uh times that your
manager now spends resolving customer
issues goes down so now the manager has
more time to coach employees so guess
what employee skill goes up this is an
example of a causal loop you start at
one variable you work your way all the
way around to the same variable again
now i'm speeding up here just a little
bit for the sake of time but let's just
go ahead and say that we somehow
exogenously increase the amount of time
that managers can spend coaching their
employees we give we i don't know we
somehow give them extra time on their
day
what does that mean
well this would imply that our
employee's skill you'd expect to go up
and if our employee still expects to go
up then we'd expect our customer
satisfaction to go up we'd expect our
complaints to correspondingly go down
based upon these causal diagrams our
complaints go down then the manager the
time spent uh resolving issues goes back
up which suddenly means that the amount
of time they have available to them goes
back up again we've gone all the way
back up the loop we've increased one
variable by a little bit and we've
gotten a positive gain around that loop
if any of you have any experience with
control theory this will look familiar
this is a a positive gain or reinforcing
loop this is a loop that uh essentially
runs away in one direction or another
when one variable starts going a little
bit up or a little bit down uh by its
action it causes a cascade of events
that causes it to go more up or more
down within that space
correspondingly we can have something i
think you guys can tell where this is
going called the balancing loop to get
ahead of myself a little bit so in this
case the general attractiveness of your
market goes up number of competitors
within that space you could imagine
would go up your product prices due to
competitive
interactions might go down this is an
example of sort of an aggregated
causal diagram i think you can make a
really strong argument that those are
not necessarily perfectly causally
related but for our
conversation it's good enough
uh product price goes down your profits
all else being equal you'd imagine would
go uh
down that's okay i think i did that one
a little backwards we'll find out any
event balancing loop so the whole idea
with a balancing loop is that a small
these are these are
um loops where they tend to uh balance
themselves out you have some sort of
external stimuli that pokes a variable
up or pokes a variable down it will act
in a way to return back to its initial
position a good example of a balancing
loop that comes up a lot is called the
goal seeking loop in this case you have
some sort of desired performance out in
the universe
and your system will act to close a gap
relative to that i'm showing you guys
the structure kind of relatively quickly
to give you some chunks of system
dynamics
compartmental models that you might see
frequently so the right way to tell if
you have a balancing or reinforcing loop
is you trace the behavior like we did
before you pick a variable you kick it
in a direction plus or minus and you see
what happens when you loop it all the
way around there's a quick way to do it
uh which is count the negatives
if there is an even number then it is a
reinforcing loop zero or even if it is
an odd number then it's a balancing loop
the part where that gets a little wonky
is that if you mislabeled it in some way
shape or form then suddenly that no
longer makes sense so that's my little
asterisk in the top corner there
stocks and flows so stocks and flows
ultimately i'm going to skip ahead a
little bit here are anything that a
stock is anything that sort of has
memory within the space so if you go
back to sort of the origins of system
dynamics and its applications and
control theory
a stock is anything whose value depends
upon the instantaneous or the
accumulation of change of two other
variables so how we tend to show this in
our spaces as is as a bucket with some
pipes so you have an inflow coming in
you have some sort of accumulation in
the middle and you have some outflow
coming out at the back end right there
this right here now allows your system
to have memory this is what your system
has when you talk about like number of
employees you talk about
um a number of units in your inventory
something else that has sort of
stickiness and time something that
instantaneously
doesn't disappear or change within one
unit of delta time but rather exists and
persists so we use something called the
hydraulic metaphor this picture the
quality of it is really low and i should
remake it this idea of a bathtub so you
have your pipe coming in you have your
pipe coming out and ultimately you can't
get rid of something in the middle
unless you add unless you add take it
out of the back end or turn down the
amount of inflow on the front end so
it's a good example this is greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere
what do you do about it there's really
only two options at the end of the day
you have to either
increase net removal or decrease net
emissions those are your two choices so
that's one thing we talked about as
stock is it's something that's that
accumulates over time uh so this is a
good example right here this is just
some some stocks versus flows your
balance sheet versus your cash flow
statement
wealth versus income and expenditures
per unit time
co2 emissions vehicle production those
are all flows part of this you can tell
is based upon how you define the
variables
at the end of the day so you have to be
a little bit careful
but i will give you this here's one that
i kind of consider a little bit tricky
interest rate
what would you consider to be an
interest rate a stock or a flow
so and i say i called it tricky so you
can probably think like oh take what you
think it is and then just flip the
answer that's what i would do so it has
the word rate in it which immediately
makes me think flow but it's actually a
rate on money it is a price it is
something that it says that if you give
me x number of dollars i will give you
back x number of dollars over
um some some period of time elapsing in
that case it is a price it is a sticky
quantity it is a stock so the word right
there is misleading
i'm going very quick guys because we we
i want to give you guys time for the
simulation so that right there is
really quick system dynamics in a
nutshell in terms of both systems
thinking and concepts and also some of
the fundamental tools that we use within
stock and flow diagrams
what i wanted to do next was transition
into actually a very large group project
that will give us some time to really
experience some of this firsthand and
then ultimately tie it back in before i
do that i want to give us a few minutes
to talk about this anyone have any
questions about either system dynamics
group at mit and we'll have some more
time at the end of this or system
dynamics and systems thinking as a sort
of methodology at this point
yeah
when do you think or when does is a
problem too complicated for you to say
system dynamics is useful what are the
bounds on usefulness of applying this to
a problem well there were things i
wouldn't necessarily say complicated is
not the right word i would say that
system dynamics is
a
poor predictor of the future when it
comes to
precision
so like there's an example of system
dynamics i think is good at making
models that project modes of behavior
but not necessarily point predictions in
the future so like a good example would
be um an oscillatory oscillatory mode
if this is your
if this is your idea of like this is
like
your mode of behavior of something over
time i don't know this is like some
price of something over
time and you make a model
that ultimately shows that given some
period some set of inputs i can do
something like affect the amplitude and
periodicity of this scale but ultimately
does show something that kind of
changes with time
but for some reason my model is just a
little bit off
the question is which is useful
knowing that i have this sort of up and
down amplitude and here are the things
or or features that either
predict a change in that in that
amplitude and frequency or is it more
useful to know that the price is going
to be this versus this at this time in
the future and the issue with any sort
of
systems model is the moment you move far
enough away from whatever your current
sort of stab and space is you can be
just as wrong as you can possibly be
when it comes to point predictions in
the future so my argument is that system
dynamics is good at
coming up with models where you can
start looking for these modes of
behavior and identifying the chunks of
structure that have a large policy
impact on affecting or adjusting these
modes of behavior not necessarily
figuring out am i going to be here or
here at time this
so that's yeah
i got to use the whiteboard so that's
fun
okay cool so
we're going to do this is a kind of
another bit of bread and butter of the
mit system dynamics group a management
flight simulator this is the whole idea
of working on mental models
ultimately getting someone's hands dirty
with something like this and kind of
getting an opportunity to experience it
firsthand
it's one of the best ways to teach
concepts from system dynamics and
systems thinking so fish banks
fish banks is a actually i'll go back
this was originally developed uh quite a
number of years ago as a board game and
i think you guys will figure out very
quickly what it sort of it's trying to
elicit out of you all this is a smart
group of folks um
but it has now been turned into kind of
this interactive simulation
so for the next hour and some change as
we go through this uh i know everyone
here has different backgrounds different
businesses different things you've been
exposed to but this is going to be your
business your business is going to be
deep sea and coastal fisher people your
job is to go out there and catch fish as
best you can and make as much money you
are all endowed with your own small
fleet of boats and your own commercial
fishing operation congratulations
welcome aboard
so i'm going to that's all i'm going to
say about fish banks again there's a lot
more stuff to kind of say about this but
i'm going to go ahead and wrap this up
because again we only have
three hours in total before i do that
any final questions about the simulation
itself any any accusations that i rigged
the whole thing and made it impossible
or anything anything fun like that any
yeah
one of the major
like one of the teams also found out
the change happened too fast and i think
that's because we didn't understood the
system or the equation behind the model
were those
information left out intentionally or
to a degree so one interesting way to
run this simulation and it's been done
but it hasn't been done for a long time
is to essentially run this whole thing
again
with you like essentially let every
person in this room play the game again
but understandably with slightly
different parameters like so you can't
just kind of set it straight to what you
want to do right off the bat so the
argument here is that information is
imperfect
but it is still present and some
information is better than no
information so the constant question is
what happens when you guys know this
information ahead of time
i'd be curious about that um for those
who did the beer game uh one of the
things that came out of that that's
interesting the beer game is this
multi-echelon supply chain the ultimate
thing about it is that information
matters information is helpful
when you play the beer game with people
who have played the beer game you still
get the exact same outcome no matter how
many times you do it and one of the
classic examples is we had a beer game
uh like championship here at mit some
years ago where not only was it people
who played before but it was professors
who teach the beer game
in the same room and we also gave
information like so typically in the
beer game there there there is there's
some
i know yeah i won't do any suppose but
even the folks who teach the beer game
didn't escape the beer game
so so part of this is is that the this
as long as this is and this is the whole
idea of structure yields behavior the
structure is still there
the underlying structure still exists
it is it is real hard to break to break
your behavior patterns when you don't
change that underlying structure
so if you want more we're all up on the
fourth floor for one thing so um at
least at least uh i don't want my door
so come on in i'll talk talk your air
off for classes here at mit
a lot of what we just talked about is
covered really in much more detail in uh
15.71 introduction system dynamics i
would say 15.871's primary purpose is to
get these ideas of systems thinking in
your head you'll be spending a lot of
time in that class
up on a chalkboard
sort of talking through problems saying
okay well let's let's talk about what
happens when you increase consumer
satisfaction what does that mean and
start drawing these lovely causal loop
diagrams and think to ourselves okay
well what happens if we snip this loop
here and what would it take to do that
so it's much more about how to get
yourself thinking from linear direction
into more of a looping direction
15.72
dives a lot more into now taking those
thought processes and applying them to
to sort of much more realistic scenarios
and situations and getting more
comfortable with modeling tools
both involve you using
software sets which i'll talk about a
little bit later that are
commonly used within system dynamics but
15.872 kind of takes the training wheels
off and there is no there is no right
there is no wrong answer as long as you
can figure out a good self-contained
simulation that gets the
the
sort of conclusion you think is
interesting uh this one's relatively new
15.873
this is somewhere that sits in between
fifteen point seven one and eight seven
two uh this is
one whose i like to think has more of an
emphasis on business and policy i have
this example down here this is the vasa
which i'm i'm now giving away a a slide
from i think 15.872 the vasa was um
an incredible ship that was uh built uh
by some of the best ship designers of
its day uh was launched and then
promptly tipped completely upside down
and sunk to the bottom of the ocean and
the reason was because at the last
minute there were several late design
heads uh suddenly decided they wanted to
build the the captain's
uh lodge a little bit larger they wanted
to add a few more sales they want to add
a ton more cannons they want to make it
more and more impressive became
hydrodynamically unstable probably
tipped over so the idea being here that
uh i emphasize that one for this idea
that you have un unintended consequences
there are no side effects there are
simply effects that you didn't plan for
and that's kind of emphasized a little
bit more in
15.72 15.873
in terms of books
i brought a few with me again i
mentioned this at the beginning of the
class this has become sort of the
the bible of system dynamics uh business
dynamics the first couple of chapters
cover a lot of what we talked about
later on it gets really specific there's
an opening in here that says essentially
if you have a background in math that's
great if you don't that's great but
later on it starts talking about the
specific differences between choosing
modes of feedback and behavior how to
model specific things really how to get
your hands dirty for uh primarily
compartmental models if you want
something a little more general uh
there's the fifth discipline field book
i wouldn't necessarily recommend the
whole book unless unless that's your
thing but part two is called systems
thinking it does a great job of
summarizing the work uh that we talked
about here both of these books are in
the dewey library i checked earlier
today i think this is the one of the two
copies of this book so i'll return it
right after this class
but there's lots of copies
of john's book on business dynamics if
you wanna know a little bit more about
sort of the history of this limits to
growth is a book that i recommend
because it has a strong history in
system dynamics it also has a bit of a
controversial history if you dive into
it um this was one of those first books
that applied the ideas of overshoot and
collapse to the earth and saying that we
as a species are are headed towards this
and we need to manage our resources and
we need to be a little bit more careful
with our choices
um the simulations in there had some
specific dates that uh ultimately were
held up as sort of the the how i point
prediction is difficult in system
dynamics so if you read it this is not a
prediction for the future it's
discussing the mode of behavior it's
talking about the structure that we
currently have that can lead to
overshooting uh collapse within shared
resources
articles if you get a chance it's my
personal favorites system dynamics at 60
the path forward
i think does a great job of kind of
saying where is system dynamics right
now a lot of material that you'll get
out there talks about where system
dynamics was 20 30 even 40 years ago
i think this one does a great job of
saying that's great what are we doing
from now this is essentially the article
that says system dynamics is not
compartmental models system dynamics is
a mode of thinking choose the software
that you need to choose the methods of
communication you need to
um
i am
a
again someone who does a lot of
operations management so most of these
choices up there about cam uh
compatibility traps um and um sort of
operational failure that's that's kind
of where i'm coming from but that being
said this one right here the sec third
one on the list making the numbers
applies a classic operations management
concept of a capability trap to um
valuation of stocks and i think that's a
great little connection right there um
if you happen to be on mit's network
these are all free and accessible the
worst case scenario i'll print out a
copy for you because i think these are
good
articles uh other websites some personal
favorites here creating creative
learning exchange um this is one it's
primarily k through 12 education focused
but there's a lot of fun little tools on
there
it uses a lot of animations make things
very approachable especially if you're
used to looking at sort of uh cold black
and white diagrams clicking around on
there just kind of makes me happy like
it has lots of like pink fluid flowing
back and forth and you like you attach
little things together they have some
fun uh ios and android applications um
tom fedeman's meta sd website is
fantastic he has
that man will just model anything that
he thinks is interesting so if you have
a blank piece of software in front of
you you don't know what to click and you
want something to as an example he has
one about like sort of the
self-reinforcing nature of ufo sightings
so he essentially thinks to himself this
is an interesting behavior i have
observed i wonder what structure could
have yielded it and then he makes it and
puts it on his website so that's just a
fun one to click around on uh this one
the self-study website that is dense to
be honest if you if but it's a good spot
to start this systematically walks you
through the fundamentals of system
dynamics from open concept to detailed
modeling systematically and is free and
open for anyone to use
i run right now the journal club so
that's my plug right there stop on by
every other friday once the semester
starts every friday once the semester
starts we have a seminar series that
system dynamics focused up on the fourth
floor if there's not a seminar scheduled
then i just kind of run the discussion
and talk about
uh something i feel like talking about
um and then of course the system
dynamics society that's our kind of our
our group society uh i would be remiss
if i did not at least mention them in
passing it's a lot of information but uh
i think especially those first two are
not ones that you see a lot are
recommended software we didn't talk at
all about software
uh if this had been a longer course that
probably would be the next thing i do is
i dive into some software with you guys
uh unfortunately we don't have the time
so i want to point you in these two
towards these guys right here vinsem and
stella architect uh vincent especially
has a free academic license if you also
have an mit email address you can get a
more or less the full commercial version
for free
which is nice the difference between the
personal learning edition and the
commercial edition is
minimal until you hit it and then once
you hit it you really want that
commercial version for being able to
just do some stuff so
if you have an mit email address i
suggest spending the three minutes to
get a eventsim
professional license
cell architect
is less used in our group but definitely
used in general
they have a great storytelling mode this
idea of building up your models
progressively without scaring people
away kind of and also have a lot of nice
visuals
i'm still getting used to that software
myself uh but i like what i see
also off to the side there net logo
not used a lot in our group necessarily
but i use it a lot it's a good old
agent-based model so sometimes it's
useful to think okay i know what a
person would do or an agent or an entity
in this setup i can i can wrap my head
around that i don't know what the system
is but i can wrap my head around one
person wandering through space this lets
you essentially model that person and
then put a whole bunch of them in a room
and see what happens if anyone has done
any sort of sort of agent-based modeling
with um
any sort of scripting language matlab r
anything else like that this is kind of
the same concept with a nice little
pretty wrapper around the outside of it
terms speaking of which in terms of
software we use all sorts of software
it's not just vinsim and stella these
are just what i have upstairs on my
machine right actually you know right
there on my machine right now and what i
use a more or less a daily basis um
we're not just compartmental models
we're a mode of thinking so if you have
a tool that gets the job done then then
good for you uh it's possible to do a
good
causal diagram using excel if you're
really motivated um
oh yeah and a whiteboard whiteboard
definitely gets the job done that's
actually he raises a great point the
most the best use is just standing in
front of our whiteboard and starting
writing some things down
people ask often ask the question what
do you do like how do you start like
what's the first thing you do
um
i'd say walk up to a whiteboard
think about the thing you care about i
don't know it's co2 in the atmosphere uh
car deaths um
number of people quitting from a
non-profit write that on a board just
write and smack dab in the middle of the
board then think to yourself what would
cause that thing to go up or down right
off to the side draw an arrow put a plus
or minus next to it and just keep going
and see what happens and let those let
those loops come back around and that's
a good spot to start
so
that's we have a few minutes i'm going
to click this one thing right here for
another example of
system dynamics in action if anyone is
familiar with the
policy interactive
this is an idea too of what's the most
complicated model sort of idea and what
can you do this is inroads
this is a
policy simulator for the climate so this
right here has a full-blown climate
simulation running on the back but its
job at the end of the day is again not
point prediction its job is policy so
again i get this is one kind of a fun
thing to click around and kind of see
system dynamics in action this is simply
saying what are we doing right here
what's our predicted temperature change
over time what are the choices that we
can make as a society as a group as a
series of countries to change this
outcome this is being used right now in
conversations with members of
our own government in order to help
elicit mental models and get people on
the same page about climate action in
the future so this is something else
where there's a
a big compartmental model running in the
background uh but this is an example of
using system dynamics to hopefully
elicit real policy change uh in the near
term so you can start clicking around
seeing what happens i'll be honest i'm
really bad at this one i click around i
realize i'm really bad at figuring out
how to fix the fix the climate which is
why i do operations in supply chain
management i suppose at the end of the
day
um so i'd encourage you guys to to click
around on that so that essentially is
where we are um
thank you guys very much i love sharing
system dynamics with you and i hope to
see some of you guys in the future thank
you
[Applause]
you